Hi everyone, thanks again for being a part of this class
and I hope you got a lot out of it.
What we covered today was different ways
to be able to create your layered materials,
the old school way, the mega scans way,
as well as the new way to be able to do so
and how efficient that works.
We also covered MPCs,
how to use material parameter collections,
how to get them set up in Sequencer
and how to just mainly get a good foundation for them
and build them within your material
to be able to do whatever you want.
We also talked about materials
in the case of subsurface profiles,
as well as subsurface materials in general
and we also looked at the occlusion parallax occlusion
and how to actually set that up
and how that works in general also.
As well as looking at advanced subsurface materials
when it came to creating such things as ice.
Each one of these topics I hope you got a lot out of
and we hope to see you soon again in our classroom.
Thanks again.